[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de vie pour
aujourd'hui j'ai le grand plaisir de
recevoir à nouveau Jocelyne Sauvard qui
sort un nouveau livre à propos de Proust
et qui est
yvelinoise par certains côtés car elle a
animé de nombreux ateliers d'écriture à
Saint-Quentin voilà Jocelyne sauvart
bonjour bonjour merci de nous retrouver
d'être fidèle à TV 78 plaisir bon
partagez alors on vous avait vu il y a
quelques temps pour un essai comme on
vous le qualifiez ce livre à Romans
c'était un roman voilà c'était Marcel
céleste et Marcel un amour de Proust ça
y est voilà céleste Albaret étant
comment dire une des femmes de sa vie
d'ailleurs sa confidente sa gouvernante
la personne qui l'a suivi jusqu'à la fin
de sa vie qui lui était dispensable
voilà elle est restée 8 ans auprès de
lui donc elle était toute jeune quand
elle est arrivée et
elle elle était fascinée par ce grand
monsieur elle veillait sur son œuvre
elle veillait sur sa vie sa santé et
puis toutes les nuits il lui racontait
ce qu'il avait fait en soirée voilà on
l'a raconté dans le précédent VIP voilà
sur Marcel et céleste céleste qui a
terminé sa carrière d'ailleurs comme
gardienne de la maison de Ravel dans les
Yvelines aussi exactement alors on ne va
pas parler que de Proust à Versailles
bien qu'il y soit qu'il y a ses journées
plusieurs fois on va parler de Proust à
l'ombre des femmes c'est le titre de
votre dernier livre qui sort aux
éditions écritures alors ce livre vous
le qualifiez de décès j'ai pas de
tromper donc je vous laisse parler
je le qualifie
d'essai et avec un petit côté roman
comme l'affaire marquer Jean-Yves tadier
il a dit votre livre c'est à la fois un
essai un roman je vous dis ce qu'il a
dit j'ai eu peut-être
précis alors Jean-Yves c'est un grand
analyse de Proust on est d'accord c'est
le plus grand le plus grand voilà ah oui
il a dit proust À l'ombre des femmes si
original passe son style et par ses
formes variées de l'essai au roman très
sensible voilà donc et bien ça explique
beaucoup de choses vous avez il y a
plusieurs personnes qui parlent dans ce
livre on est d'accord on est d'accord
alors dites-moi qui alors il y a la
narratrice c'est une
c'est une jeune fille très littrée qui
adore la littérature qui pourrait être
vous il y a quelques années sans être
désagréable
et donc au même âge bon ça n'est pas moi
c'est une narratrice comme Proust a pris
un narrateur pour raconter tous les
volumes de la recherche du temps perdu
et donc voilà et elle rencontre ce grand
écrivain une fois comme ça tout à fait
par hasard et puis plus tard on lui
demande si elle veut venir
de toute urgence corriger les dernières
épreuves où tout le moins vérifier s'il
ne manque pas un blanc s'il a pas un
esque etc et donc elle vient auprès de
lui à chaque fois qu'il appelle et elle
corrige les épreuves et donc un lien
secret entre d'accord après on a aussi
Marcel Proust lui-même voilà qui parle
donc ça ce sont les citations de son
oeuvre et puis on a le son narrateur
c'est-à-dire le héros de la recherche du
temps perdu parce que comme il explique
longuement il n'est pas lui le héros
entièrement il y a toute la part de
fiction tous l'imaginaire qui est là
donc c'est le narrateur qui d'accord
ressemble beaucoup à Marcel pouce mais
qui n'est pas écrivain dans la recherche
du temps perdu et il va le devenir à la
fin du dernier volume le Temps retrouvé
c'est à dire que c'est toute l'histoire
à l'envers d'accord je comprends alors
tout ça
alors c'est dans quel but j'ai envie de
vous dire vous avez voulu nous montrer
un autre regard nous ouvrir une autre
porte tout à fait parce qu'on a écrit
déjà beaucoup de choses sur proustiers
d'abord un Proust amoureux sensuel
caressant faux des femmes de leur beauté
et puis j'ai voulu montrer aussi parce
ce côté à la fois il sert au Mans j'ai
voulu m'inspirer de ce qu'il avait fait
dans contre sainte boeuf qui est moins
connu que tout oui
alors c'est un essai avec une partie
roman une partie pastiche et une partie
critique littéraire parce
qu'effectivement il n'aimait pas les
critiques littéraires de Sainte-Baume
certaines étaient très intéressantes
mais il croyait que
jamais un auteur n'utilise son
imagination mais sa vie privée tout le
temps Proust
voilà et donc Proust veut absolument
prouver le contraire il y a notre
imagination c'est vraiment notre plus
fidèle entité pour créer c'est le titre
de travail c'est la matière voilà voilà
après on va l'alimenter comme on veut et
la mémoire les jeux de la mémoire qui ne
sont pas de A à Z les yeux de la mémoire
on ne raconte pas il est né là et il est
mort là on se souvient par exemple d'un
événement et puis cinq minutes après on
repense bon Baba qu'on a dégusté il y a
trois ans voilà vous voyez ressenti
voilà toutes les choses de sensations
qui reviennent dans nos mémoires donc on
peut penser d'ailleurs à la fameuse
Madeleine exactement voilà bon revenons
à nos moutons
à savoir les femmes alors quelles sont
elles ces femmes à l'ombre duquel se
trouve Proust alors d'abord bien sûr il
y a sa mère Jeanne proustilla éprouvé
elle était d'une grande douceur elle est
éprouvait grandement c'est affection
pour son enfant un premier né qui était
un peu délicat de santé et ensuite il a
eu un frère deux ans après Robert qui
lui était plus costaud les deux frères
sont tombés très bien et voilà mais ils
étaient complètement différents l'un de
l'autre et
donc voilà madame Proust Jeanne Proust
elle était belle elle était elle avait
une belle voix elle lui racontait des
histoires elle se trouve à droite
et donc voilà et il y a eu d'autres
femmes évidemment il y a eu sa
grand-mère aussi qui était très tendre
et qui était aussi une sorte
d'éducatrice un peu comme dans un peu
beaucoup comme dans la recherche de
temps perdu contrôle de la grand-mère
est importante et puis après il y a eu
aussi les petites jeunes filles qui l'a
rencontré en allant jouer au jardin des
Champs-Élysées
il faut donc savoir que Proust était de
constitution extrêmement fragile
asthmatique
donc j'imagine très protégé très couvée
et vous dites dans le livre que sa mère
l'éloignait
des autres jeunes filles oui quand il
était un peu plus grand qu'il avait 14
15 ans elle éloignait des autres jeunes
filles mais au parc elle tolérer très
très bien je pense qu'il avait le droit
voilà Antoinette et Lucie les filles du
futur président Faure voilà donc il
jouait avec elle mais lui il avait aussi
Proust et le narrateur son narrateur
avait aussi une espèce d'élan vers une
jeune fille
ravissante qui avait 14 ans 14 15 ans
lui de même et qui était très vives très
gai et qui s'appelait dans la réalité
Marie de Bernard daquie d'accord donc il
a connu à quel âge alors 14 ans bon
alors à quel moment elle intervient
madame Proust la maman Proust pour le
pour préserver un petit peu
son fils pour elle toute seule non pour
elle toute seule peut-être pas vraiment
mais en tout cas veillez à sa témorale
c'est-à-dire toute la famille veille à
sa santé morale physique et assez
sexualité puisque ils étaient très libre
de parole et d'écrits donc il pouvait
écrire à son grand-père s'il avait des
petits soucis de ce côté-là et le père
et le grand-père c'était mis en tête de
le faire aller dans les maisons closes
j'ai pas toujours amusant pour un très
jeune homme
ça l'a pas les spécialement et puis en
plus qu'on a l'oeil sur lui quand même
c'était un peu gênant bon voilà ceci mis
à part la famille s'entendait très bien
et elle avait été douée d'humour comme
lui et puis bien sûr s'intéresser à la
littérature moi ce que je propose c'est
qu'en fait on se plonge dans ce livre
parce qu'il y a beaucoup d'autres femmes
et alors aimant il y a Anna de Noailles
avait qui l'a des liens très
particuliers et on se rend compte aussi
grâce à qui est en fin de livre donc ça
gouvernante à la façon dont il va un peu
à la pêche et en fait il n'était
qu'observation ne vivait pas vraiment
lui-même les choses par à la fin de sa
vie il cherchait de la matière assez
romans oui mais en même temps tout ce
qu'il avait vécu tout ce qu'il avait en
magazine et toutes les sensations toutes
les choses qui devinaient chez les gens
qui le rencontrait que ce soit des gens
du faubourg Saint-Germain comme on dit
dans le livre qui en fait se trouvait
beaucoup beaucoup vers
Saint-Honoré et bien
toutes ces choses en surgissaient comme
elles ressurgissent dans notre mémoire
c'est pourquoi le livre est facile à
lire si on veut entrer dans dans
l'oeuvre de Proust et dans sa vie pour
la première fois alors voilà on va y
venir c'était un peu ma dernière
question d'accord imaginons qu'on n'est
jamais lu prout c'est le cas de pas mal
de monde quand même oui bien sûr
évidemment comment il y a une espèce
d'entre soi on entend les gens parler
alors la recherche la recherche on se
gargarise un peu de ce nom une espèce de
petit clan on en est où on en est pas
alors du coup ça peut-être effrayer les
gens comment incliner les gens à lire
Proust et leur donner envie et je pense
que ça peut effrayer les gens voir les
jeunes mais il se trouve que les jeunes
que je rencontre moi ne sont pas
effrayés parce que on en parle et puis
on lit des passages ensemble et puis de
si de là en laissant des blancs et bien
eux ont envie de découvrir la suite et
puis dans le livre par exemple comme
j'ai pris cette narratrice qui a l'âge
du jeune gens jusqu'à la croix 16-18 ans
voilà
auquel on peut lire Proust oui tout à
fait et là je me suis un petit peu
inspirée de moi parce que j'ai le projet
à partir de 15 ans et je ne l'ai jamais
quitté
d'accord en vacances nous vous
conseillez de commencer par par quelle
œuvre alors bien laisser les jeux de la
mémoire tout au long on a on a moi j'ai
commencé par un amour de projet un amour
de projet
voilà donc c'était passionnant très
drôle il montrait du ratio
des drôles et oui des drones et donc
voilà j'ai beaucoup ri avec l'histoire
du petit clan madame Verdurin des gens
snobs qui qui sont très fermés
qui n'accepte personne chez eux qui a
d'autres moments seront être généreux et
ça c'était très drôle mais en même sur
tout ce qui m'avait passionné à 15 ans
c'était l'histoire d'amour de Swan et de
et doit être donc avec la jalousie qui
avait un rôle prépond et puis aussi
l'attirance le désir donc voilà et puis
si on lit pas seulement un amour de peau
mais si on lit carrément un amour de soi
mais si on lit carrément du côté de chez
soi on voit aussi l'enfant l'enfance et
de Marcel Pauchet de son narrateur qui a
du mal à s'endormir qui cherche sa mère
et qui après grandit et va vers vers les
jeunes filles ok nous irons voilà bon on
m'a volé une porte ouverte à franchir
peut-être avant d'aborder l'oeuvre de
Proust pour ce qui ne la connaissent pas
oui tout à fait et les projets l'aiment
beaucoup aussi en plus voilà l'aiment
beaucoup parce que justement cette
construction
un peu à la manière de contre-sander les
intéresse beaucoup parce que récit comme
ça à deux voix trois voix dont celle de
mars elle prousse
ça les intéresse voilà très bien ben
écoutez un grand merci Justine Sauvard
et à très bientôt pour une nouvelle
aventure avec grand plaisir au revoir à
tous merci de nous avoir suivi à très
vite pour un nouveau VIP
[Musique]